KELLYANNE CONWAY.
♪
PETE: PRESIDENT TRUMP’S COVID-19
DIAGNOSIS COMES JUST ONE MONTH
UNTIL THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
HOW WILL THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN STAY
VISIBLE FOR THE REMAINDER OF THE
RACE.
JOINING ME NOW SENIOR ADVISERS
TO THE TRUMP 2020 CAMPAIGN AND
CO-AUTHORS OF THE BRAND NEW BOOK
"TRUMP AMERICA FIRSTST" COREY
LEWANDOWSKI AND DAVID BOSSIE.
COREY, DAVID, THANK YOU BOTH FOR
BEING HERE.
LET’S START OFF ON THE
PRESIDENT’S SIDE AND THEN WE
WILL GET TO THE POLITICAL
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS.
I SAT ONE ROW IN FRONT OF YOU
BOTH IN THE ROSE GARDEN FOR THE
NOMINATION OF AMY CONEY BARRETT.
YOU HAVE BEEN AROUND THE
PRESIDENT RECENTLY.
COREY, IF YOU WOULD, TAKE US
INSIDE YOUR OWN PERSONAL
CONSIDERATIONS AS WELL AS THE
INNER CIRCLE AROUND THE
PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW.
>> YOU KNOW, PETE, YOU DID HAVE
A MUCH BETTER SEAT THAN US
BECAUSE YOU ARE MUCH MORE
IMPORTANT.
SO CONGRATULATIONS ON THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
HERE IS THE TRUTH, PETE, AND YOU
KNOW THIS AND THE LISTENERS
SHOULD KNOW.
THIS EVERY TIME YOU WALK ONTO
THE WHITE HOUSE COMPLEX YOU ARE
TESTED FOR COVID-19.
WE WERE TESTED ON SATURDAY
BEFORE THAT ROSE GARDEN
CEREMONY.
I WAS WITH THE PRESIDENT ON
WEDNESDAY PRIVATE FUNDRAISER.
I WAS TESTED BEFORE I EVEN
WALKED INTO THE DOOR TO THE
FACILITY.
AND I WAS TESTED AGAIN YESTERDAY
HERE IN HIGH HOME STATE OF NEW
HAMPSHIRE.
ALL THREE TIMES I TESTED
NEGATIVE FOR COVID-19.
AND THOSE ARE THE PROTOCOLS AND
PRECAUTIONS THAT THE TEAM HAS
HAD IN PLACE TO KEEP THE
PRESIDENT AND THE FIRST FAMILY
SAFE.
SO THAT IS WHAT HAS HAPPENED SO
FAR.
AND I’M SURE THEY ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THOSE
PROTOCOLS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
CAN CONTINUE TO KEEP THEM SAFE.
PETE: DAVID, THE CAMPAIGN
CONTINUES, THE RUNNING THE
COUNTRY CONTINUES.
WILL THERE BE ANY CHANGE IN THE
WAY THINGS OPERATE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE OR THE CAMPAIGN?
>> PETE, WE JUST WENT THROUGH
THIS WITH THE LOCKDOWN IN THE
SPRING, RIGHT?
SO THE CAMPAIGN HAD TO
TRANSITION FROM A TRADITIONAL
CAMPAIGN THAT WE WERE DOING TO A
VIRTUAL CAMPAIGN AND NOW WE ARE
GOING TO SHIFT BACK TO THAT BILL
STEPPIAN AND HIS TEAM ARE GOING
TO BE LEADING THAT AND COREY AND
I ARE GOING TO BE EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF US EVERY TRUMP SUPPORTER
IN THE COUNTRY HAS TO PICK UP
THE BANNER AND HELP OUT RIGHT
NOW.
YOU LOOK IN MARYLAND RIGHT NOW
THERE ARE PEOPLE ORGANICALLY
SHOWING UP IN FRONT OF WALTER
REED, SHOWING THEIR LOVE TO THIS
COUNTRY.
IT’S AN AMAZING THING TO SEE.
WHEETION THE BALANCE IN THE
PRESIDENT IS AT WALTER REED.
HAS THE ABILITY TO RUN THE
COUNTRY FROM THERE.
HAS A CAMPAIGN TO RUN.
WHAT’S YOUR ADVICE ON HOW
VISIBLE HE SHOULD BE.
>> WE KNOW THE PRESIDENT HAS A
UNIQUE COMMUNICATION STYLE
WHETHER HE IS WITH ONE PERSON OR
A THOUSAND SUPPORTERS OR CALLING
N TO SHOWS OR TWEETING OR USING
A SOCIAL MEDIA ACTIVITY.
I’M CERTAIN THAT OVER THE COURSE
OF THE NEXT MANY DAYS WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HEAR FROM THE
PRESIDENT.
HE HAS PUT OUT A FEW TWEETS.
HE PUT OUT A VIDEO YESTERDAY.
SO THE ONE THING THAT IS CERTAIN
IS THAT THIS PRESIDENT IS GOING
TO CONTINUE TO COMMUNICATE
DIRECTLY WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
HE WILL CONTINUE TO GIVE
PROGRESS UPDATES.
I HAD THE CHANCE TO SPEAK WITH
CHIEF OF STAFF MEADOWS LAST
NIGHT ABOUT HOW THE PRESIDENT
WAS DOING AT WALTER REED.
HE SAID HE WAS IN GREAT SPIRITS.
AND HE IS READY TO CONTINUE TO
FIGHT EVERY DAY FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IS HE GOING TO BEAT COVID.
IS HE WARRIOR.
HE IS GOING TO KEEP FIGHTING FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE EVERY DAY.
PETE: DAVID, ALONG THOSE LINES
ANY REASON TO BELIEVE THE DEBATE
DOESN’T HAPPEN?
ANYTHING GOING FORWARD THAT
CHANGES?
>> NO, THE DEBATES ARE GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THERE IS NO REASON FOR THEM NOT
TO.
IF THEY HAVE TO BE PUSHED-OUT
SECOND DEBATE HAS TO BE PUSHED A
DAY OR TWO THAT’S NOTHING.
WE NEED THIS PRESIDENT TO
RECOVER.
BUT HE IS A FIGHTER AND HE IS A
FIGHTER FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT’S WHY HE WAS ELECTED TO
BEGIN WITH.
AND HE IS -- HE IS SUCH A
FIGHTER.
IS HE GOING TO BEAT COVID AND
JOE BIDEN ALL AT THE SAME TIME.
SO WE’RE LOOKINGNG FORWARD TO TH
NEXT 30 DAYS OF THIS CAMPAIGN OF
TELLING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THE
GOOD NEWS OF WHAT HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS HAVE BEEN AND
WHAT HE HAS DONE TO LOWER THEIR
TAXES TO MAKE THEIR LIVES BETTER
TO BRING JOBS BACK TO AMERICA.
IT’S A GREAT STORY.
NONE OF THAT CHANGES.
HIS L LIST OF ACCOMPLISHMENTS IS
LIKE NOTHING THAT WE HAVE EVER
SEEN AND HE HAS DONE MORE IN 47
MONTHS AND THIS JOE BIDEN HAS
DONE IN 47 YEARS.
NOTHING ABOUT COVID IS GOING TO
CHANGE THOSE FACTS.
PETE: REAL QUICK, COREY TO THE
PARTICULARS.
DO YOU EXPECT VIRTUAL EVENTS?
DO YOU EXPECT HIM TO CALL INTO
SHOWS?
WHAT, YOU KNOW, ANYTHING IN
PARTICULAR CAN YOU GIVE AS YOU
GLIMPSE OF?
>> YOU KNOW, PETE, IT’S TO BE
DETERMINED.
I DO THINK YOU ARE CLEARLY GOING
TO SEAT PRESIDENT CALLING INTO
SHOWS.
DOING POTENTIALLY TELEPHONE TOWN
HALL RALLIES.
CONTINUING TO COMMUNICATE.
THERE IS NO VIRUS THAT’S GOING
TO STOP THIS PRESIDENT FROM
CONTINUING TO TALK TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE DIRECTLY.
HE HAS DONE IT SO SUCCESSFULLY
OVER THE LAST SIX YEARS SINCE
THE CAMPAIGN STARTED.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO STOP HIM AT
ALL.
PETE: ALL RIGHT, GUYS, SPEAKING
OF SUCCESS.
HAVE YOU HAD SUCCESSFUL BOOKS IN
THE PAST.
CONGRATULATIONS ON TRUMP,
AMERICA FIRST.
IT’S AVAILABLE NOW.
HOPE FOLK ALSO CHECK IT OUT.